The guy who takes tickets in the office parking garage. The colleague in another department who used to take a coffee break at the same time as you. The parents at monthly PTA meetings. The commuters you shared a subway car with every morning. Remember them? Before the pandemic, these wide circles of acquaintances and strangers were the backdrop of our daily lives. Familiar, comforting, something we took for granted. Over the past year, as many of us have lamented our physical separation from close
那个在办公室停车场收停车费的人。那个以前和你同一时间休息喝咖啡的部门同事。每个月家长会上的家长们。每天早上和你共乘一辆地铁的通勤者。还记得他们吗？疫情之前，这些广泛的熟人和陌生人是我们日常生活的背景。熟悉、令人安心，是我们认为理所当然的存在。在过去的一年里，当我们许多人感叹与亲密
friends and family, how many of us have thought about missing those casual connections? When's the last time you actually spoke to a stranger? And despite the fact that so many of us profess to dislike making small talk, it turns out that these kinds of connections and conversations actually strengthen our mental health and enrich our lives. So what do we gain from meeting new people and chatting with strangers? What have we been missing out on this past year? And as life begins to go back to normal in the coming months, we hope. How can we become better at meeting new people and embracing the opportunity to talk to strangers?
朋友和家人身体上的疏离时，有多少人想过会怀念那些随意的联系？你上一次真正和陌生人交谈是什么时候？尽管我们许多人都声称不喜欢闲聊，但事实证明，这类联系和对话实际上能增强我们的心理健康，丰富我们的生活。那么，我们从结识新朋友和与陌生人聊天中获得了什么？过去这一年我们错过了什么？随着未来几个月生活开始恢复正常，我们希望如此。我们怎样才能更擅长结识新朋友并抓住与陌生人交谈的机会呢？
Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. We have two guests today. Dr. Gillian Sandstrom is a senior lecturer in psychology at the University of Essex in the United Kingdom.
欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。今天我们有两位嘉宾。吉莉安·桑德斯特罗姆博士是英国埃塞克斯大学的心理学高级讲师。
She studies what she calls minimal social interactions and has found that despite many people's reluctance to talk to strangers, these interactions are usually enjoyable and actually are good for us. She's become an advocate for the benefits of talking to strangers, has spoken widely on the topic and even developed a workshop called How to Talk to Strangers. Our second guest is John Levy, a consultant, writer, and speaker who has had a lot of opportunity to watch strangers talk to one another. More than a decade ago, he founded what he calls the influencers dinner, regular gatherings that brought strangers together who are leaders in their fields, Olympic athletes, business executives, Nobel Prize winners, artists, musicians, and others to cook dinner and converse with each other without at first knowing any other guest's identity. His book, You're Invited, The Art and Science of Cultivating Influence, will be released in May. It talks about the importance of making human connections and building trust and community. to accomplish our goals. Thank you both for joining us today.
她研究的是她所说的“微小社交互动”，并发现尽管许多人不愿意与陌生人交谈，但这些互动通常是令人愉快的，而且实际上对我们有益。她已成为倡导与陌生人交谈益处的人，就这一话题进行了广泛的演讲，甚至开发了一个名为“如何与陌生人交谈”的工作坊。我们的第二位嘉宾是乔恩·列维，他是一位顾问、作家和演说家，有很多机会观察陌生人之间的交谈。十多年前，他创办了所谓的“影响者晚宴”，这是一种定期的聚会，将各领域的领袖、奥运选手、企业高管、诺贝尔奖得主、艺术家、音乐家等陌生人聚集在一起，让他们在最初不知道其他客人身份的情况下一起做饭和交谈。他的书《你被邀请了：培养影响力的艺术与科学》将于五月出版。书中谈到了建立人际联系、建立信任和社区以实现我们目标的重要性。感谢两位今天加入我们。
I think your different perspectives should make for a really interesting conversation. Looking forward to our chat. I'm super excited to be here. I'm dying to dive into like Jillian's research. I can't wait to see what I can apply to my dinner parties and events. Well, we will get there. Let's start with you, Dr. Sandstrom. As I mentioned in the introduction, you study minimal social interactions.
我想你们不同的视角应该会促成一场非常有趣的对话。期待我们的交流。我非常兴奋能来到这里。我迫不及待地想深入了解吉莉安的研究。我等不及要看看我能把什么应用到我的晚宴和活动中了。好吧，我们会谈到的。让我们从你开始，桑德斯特罗姆博士。正如我在介绍中提到的，你研究的是微小社交互动。
Can you define that? Well, I think I'll answer that question by kind of giving my origin story or one of my origin stories. So when I started studying my master's degree, which I did at Ryerson University, which is right downtown Toronto in Canada, so just right in the middle of the city. And I would walk from the research lab to my supervisor's office. And when I did that, I would pass a hot dog stand. And I somehow, without meaning to, developed a relationship with the lady who worked at the hot dog stand. And every day when I walked to, I was a hot dog stand. And every day when I walked past her. I would smile and wave and she would wave back. And it just really made me feel good.
你能定义一下吗？嗯，我想我会通过讲述我的起源故事或其中一个起源故事来回答这个问题。当我开始攻读硕士学位时，我是在加拿大多伦多市中心的瑞尔森大学，就在城市正中央。我会从研究实验室走到我导师的办公室。当我这样做时，我会经过一个热狗摊。不知何故，我无意中与在热狗摊工作的那位女士建立了一种关系。每天我走过去时，那是一个热狗摊。每天我走过她身边时，我都会微笑并挥手，她也会挥手回应。这真的让我感觉很好。
And so I just started wondering, what's going on here? Is this just me or is this a thing? And that's how I ended up doing this research. So it started from there. And I guess I look at the kind of relationships that they have that, at least when I started, I was looking at what I call weak ties, which is kind of one step up from a stranger, you know, someone like the hot dog lady or the kind people you mentioned during the intro. So not strangers because there's mutual recognition. So I think that's the sort of, you know, tiny line between a stranger and a weak tie. But I've been more interested in the ones on the more minimal side than the acquaintances that we see on a regular basis and are actually quite close to. So I think that the word acquaintance
于是我开始想，这是怎么回事？这只是我个人的情况，还是普遍现象？这就是我最终进行这项研究的原因。所以它从那里开始。我想我关注的是那种关系，至少在我开始时，我研究的是我所说的“弱关系”，这比陌生人高出一个层级，你知道，就像热狗摊女士或你在介绍中提到的那些友善的人。所以不是陌生人，因为有相互的认可。所以我认为这就是陌生人和弱关系之间那条细微的界限。但我对那些比我们定期见面且实际上相当亲近的熟人更微小的互动更感兴趣。所以我认为“熟人”这个词
can be really, really broad. It encompasses a lot of people. And I've been more interested on the more minimal side. So a lot of your research has found that people were, about talking to strangers. We all are a little uncomfortable with the idea. We don't think that they'll enjoy it or that the other person will enjoy being talked to. Why is that? Are these worries valid? Well, the easy answer to that second part is, no, they are not. I mean, they're not accurate. Maybe it makes sense that we have them. And yeah, my research has found, you know, over the last 10 years I've been doing this research and I've done lots of different studies. And I find people are just worried about so many different things. So they're worried about how they're going to feel
可以非常非常宽泛。它涵盖了很多人。而我对更微小的那一端更感兴趣。所以你的很多研究发现，人们对于和陌生人交谈感到……我们都对这个想法感到有点不舒服。我们认为他们不会喜欢，或者对方不会喜欢被搭话。这是为什么？这些担忧有根据吗？嗯，对后半部分的简单回答是，不，它们没有根据。我的意思是，它们不准确。也许我们有这些担忧是有道理的。是的，我的研究发现，你知道，在过去10年里我一直在做这项研究，我做了很多不同的研究。我发现人们只是担心很多不同的事情。他们担心自己会感觉如何
about the conversation and whether they have the skills to maintain the conversation. But they're also equally worried about their conversation partner. Is that person going to like me? Are they going to want to talk to me? Are they going to be able to carry on this conversation? Are we going to have one of those dreaded awkward silences? So yeah, generally speaking, people are quite worried about all sorts of things, but when you actually get them to have a conversation and report back afterwards, they kind of have to admit that none of those things they worried about really happened. And over and over again, I find that people enjoy their conversations much more than they expect to.
关于对话，以及他们是否有能力维持对话。但他们同样担心他们的谈话对象。那个人会喜欢我吗？他们会想和我说话吗？他们能继续这个对话吗？我们会陷入那种可怕的尴尬沉默吗？所以是的，总的来说，人们对各种事情都很担心，但当你真正让他们进行对话并事后反馈时，他们不得不承认他们担心的那些事情并没有真正发生。我一次又一次地发现，人们享受对话的程度远超他们的预期。
So, John, through your influencer dinners and now your influencer Zooms, you've had a lot of opportunity to watch strangers talk to each other. Tell us a little bit about these events and why you started this project. So I was 28 years old, overweight in debt, and literally like the poster child for not living up to your potential. And I came across some research by Nicholas Christakis and James Fowler about the spread of obesity. They were curious, does it spread like a cold from person to person or is it a percentage of the population? and they found that if you have a friend who's obese, your probability of obesity increases by 45%.
那么，乔恩，通过你的影响者晚宴，现在还有你的影响者Zoom会议，你有很多机会观察陌生人之间的交谈。给我们讲讲这些活动，以及你为什么开始这个项目。我当时28岁，超重，负债累累，简直就是没有发挥潜力的典型代表。我偶然发现了尼古拉斯·克里斯塔基斯和詹姆斯·福勒关于肥胖传播的研究。他们很好奇，肥胖是像感冒一样在人与人之间传播，还是人口中的一个比例？他们发现，如果你有一个肥胖的朋友，你患肥胖症的概率会增加45%。
Your friends who don't know them have a 20% increased chance, and their friends have a 5% increased chance. And so I figured rather than beating myself up for not wanting to set an alarm at 6 a.m. to work out, maybe I could get contagious behaviors like exercise, or better financial habits just by getting to know people. And I realized that that would be compounded if I could get all these strangers that are really successful
你那些不认识他们的朋友患病几率增加20%，而他们的朋友患病几率增加5%。所以我认为，与其因为不想在早上6点定闹钟去锻炼而自责，不如通过结识他人来获得像锻炼或更好的财务习惯这样具有传染性的行为。我意识到，如果我能让所有这些非常成功的陌生人
to know each other because then they could positively influence one another. And so I started modeling their behavior and trying to figure out what they would want to engage with. And I realized that it needs to be something novel and there are a few other characteristics. And so I think, Jillian, you've probably seen this in your work as well. There's this weird characteristics that we all have called the IKEA effect, which states that we disproportionately care about
互相认识，这种效果会加倍，因为他们可以积极地影响彼此。所以我开始模仿他们的行为，试图弄清楚他们想参与什么。我意识到这需要是一些新颖的东西，还有其他一些特征。所以我认为，吉莉安，你可能在你的工作中也看到了这一点。我们都有一个奇怪的特征，叫做“宜家效应”，它指出我们不成比例地关心
our IKEA furniture because we had to assemble it. So because of this ridiculous trait that when we invest effort into something we care about it more, I realized I was going to invite people to do something together. And I ended up falling on cooking a meal. And the big joke is that after a bunch of these dinners, it was probably like five, six years in. We had a famous journalist come and she said, I was expecting a phenomenal meal and decent company. I got the exact opposite. So it's terrible. Like the meals are awful. I mean, they're fine, right? But go to Chipotle, you'll have a better meal. But what I found is that, and the research, I believe, really supports this, is that a shared activity functions as a social catalyst that eliminates a lot of
我们的宜家家具，因为我们必须自己组装它。因为这个荒谬的特质，即当我们投入精力时，我们就会更关心它，我意识到我要邀请人们一起做点什么。我最终决定做饭。最大的笑话是，在举办了这么多晚宴之后，大概是五六年了。我们有一位著名的记者来参加，她说：“我期待着一顿美味的饭菜和体面的陪伴。我得到的恰恰相反。”所以这很糟糕。饭菜很糟糕。我的意思是，它们还可以，对吧？但去Chipotle吃，你会吃到更好的饭菜。但我发现，而且我相信研究确实支持这一点，共享活动起到了社交催化剂的作用，消除了很多
the awkwardness and concern. So if I ask people to move a table or chop some vegetables, conversation actually flows much faster and more naturally. Does that ring true for you, Jillian? Is that what you see in your research too? I mean, just speaking from personal experience, I mean, I get asked a lot about tips for starting a conversation. And I mean, basically what you're talking about, John, is sort of a built-in conversation starter. And everybody there has something in common. because they've all chosen to take you up on this, you know, crazy, somewhat crazy endeavor. So in some ways, there's sort of built-in things that would make it easier to talk.
尴尬和担忧。所以如果我请人们搬一张桌子或切一些蔬菜，对话实际上会流淌得更快、更自然。这对你有共鸣吗，吉莉安？你在你的研究中也看到了这一点吗？我的意思是，仅从个人经验来说，很多人问我关于开启对话的技巧。我的意思是，基本上你所说的，乔恩，是一种内置的对话开启器。而且那里的每个人都有共同点，因为他们都选择了接受你这个，你知道，疯狂的、有点疯狂的尝试。所以在某种程度上，有一些内置的东西会让交谈变得更容易。
But I'm curious to ask you a question. Like, do you sometimes see people worrying about the conversation? Because even, you know, even the kinds of people that you're inviting, surely, there's some among them that are less extroverted and more sort of socially anxious. And so I'm curious if you see that kind of fears that I'm talking about. about. Oh, without a doubt. I think that you're spot on with everything that you've said, both the concern. And there's actually a secondary concern. Because they're coming into the home of a stranger, about like 15 minutes in, the first part we do kind of like cocktails, maybe show people
但我很好奇想问你一个问题。比如，你有时会看到人们担心对话吗？因为即使是，你知道，即使是你邀请的那种人，肯定也有一些人是不那么外向、更倾向于社交焦虑的。所以我很好奇你是否看到了我所说的那种恐惧。哦，毫无疑问。我认为你所说的一切都非常准确，包括那种担忧。而且实际上还有一种次要的担忧。因为他们进入了一个陌生人的家，大约15分钟后，我们做的第一部分有点像鸡尾酒会，也许会带人们
the house that they're in. But after about 15 minutes in, once like people have relaxed a little, they'll say, oh, I'm so sorry, I just have to call my spouse and let them know that I still have both of my kidneys. Right. Like, I haven't been kidnapped. This isn't some like organ scam. And that's probably like less of a concern when you're on this like a, I don't know, a bus. And you're not worried that the person who turns to you and asks you about the book you're reading is after your kidneys. Well, funny enough though, like when I talk to someone on the bus, I actually assume that there's sort of these three stages that people are going through. And this is not something I've actually tested.
参观他们所在的房子。但在大约15分钟后，一旦人们放松了一些，他们会说：“哦，我很抱歉，我必须给我的配偶打个电话，让他们知道我的两个肾脏还在。”对吧。就像，我没有被绑架。这不是什么器官骗局。当你坐在，我不知道，一辆公共汽车上时，这种担忧可能就比较少。你不担心那个转向你并问你正在读什么书的人是冲着你的肾脏来的。嗯，有趣的是，当我与公共汽车上的人交谈时，我实际上假设人们正在经历这三个阶段。这不是我实际测试过的东西。
But I assume that people's first thought is, you know, do I know you? because, you know, people don't just talk to each other that often. So it's so they think, well, you know, if you're talking to me, it must, you must have a reason for it. And so the first thought is, you know, maybe I know you. And once they realize, uh-oh, I don't know you, then they do start to worry. I think they think, you know, you must be trying to get something. Maybe you're trying to sell something or maybe you, you know, you're crazy or maybe, like, maybe you do want to harm them. And then I think, you know, if you have to persist a little bit and get to the point where people realize you're just
但我假设人们的第一反应是，你知道，“我认识你吗？”因为，你知道，人们并不经常这样互相交谈。所以他们会想，好吧，你知道，如果你在和我说话，你一定有一个理由。所以第一反应是，你知道，也许我认识你。一旦他们意识到，“哦，不，我不认识你”，那么他们就开始担心了。我想他们会想，你知道，你一定想得到什么。也许你想卖什么东西，或者也许你，你知道，你疯了，或者也许，就像，也许你真的想伤害他们。然后我想，你知道，如果你必须坚持一下，达到人们意识到你只是
being friendly. You just want to have a chat. And if you can get to that point, then you're golden. But sometimes, you know, it can take longer with some people to get to that point. And some people will never be able to get there because they just have too much anxiety and get stuck on, stuck in the middle somewhere. So I'm super curious about something. It seems that, uh, that in general, anxiety and concern has increased over the past, let's say, 30, 40 years in terms of our safety, right? So according to most statistics, we're in the U.S., at least, safer in just about every way. But there's this rise of helicopter parenting and, like, this fear of talking to strangers. Over the past 10 years, have you seen that there's greater concern?
表现友好。你只是想聊聊天。如果你能达到那一点，那么你就成功了。但有时，你知道，对某些人来说，达到那一点可能需要更长的时间。有些人永远无法达到那里，因为他们有太多的焦虑，被困在中间的某个地方。所以我对一件事非常好奇。似乎，呃，总的来说，在过去，比如说，30、40年里，关于我们的安全，焦虑和担忧有所增加，对吧？所以根据大多数统计数据，我们至少在美国，在几乎所有方面都更安全。但出现了“直升机式育儿”和，比如，这种害怕与陌生人交谈的现象。在过去10年里，你是否看到这种担忧有所增加？
Or do you think it's kind of stayed about the same? I mean, as a psychologist, I don't tend to do the sort of studying things over time and looking at the history of it. I'd love to work with someone on those kind of questions. But, I mean, I think, you know, I don't want to be blaming social media for all of the world's problems because that doesn't make any sense. But I think young people especially can use social media and use their phones to sort of avoid having too much. face-to-face interaction with people. And if you don't have that practice to build up the skills, then you could build it up in your head as something that's really fearful.
还是你认为它基本保持不变？我的意思是，作为一名心理学家，我不倾向于做那种随时间推移研究事物并观察其历史的工作。我很乐意与某人合作研究这类问题。但是，我的意思是，我认为，你知道，我不想把世界上所有的问题都归咎于社交媒体，因为那没有意义。但我认为年轻人尤其可以使用社交媒体和手机来避免过多的面对面互动。如果你没有那种练习来建立技能，那么你可能会在脑海中把它构建成一件非常可怕的事情。
And then because you don't have a lot of practice, you try it, it doesn't go so well. And then you start to think, I don't have the skills to do this. And then it becomes even scarier. And you get into this sort of negative cycle. So I suspect that, and not just talking about young people, but the world is sort of set up. we're trying to make things more and more efficient, and we're factoring out a lot of the opportunities for social interaction.
然后因为你没有太多的练习，你尝试了，结果不太好。然后你开始想，我没有能力做这件事。然后它变得更加可怕。你陷入了这种负面循环。所以我怀疑，不仅仅是谈论年轻人，而是世界在某种程度上被设定了。我们试图让事情变得越来越高效，我们正在剔除许多社交互动的机会。
You know, there was an article in the news recently about how, you know, there's going to be a new grocery store that has no human checkouts. Like, everybody just sort of swipes and walks out the door. And, you know, like, we're doing these kind of things for certain reasons, but, you know, it has these negative consequences, which is taking away some of this human contact. and I don't know. I think especially right now with the pandemic, I hope it reminds us that we're all kind of,
你知道，最近新闻里有一篇文章说，将要有一家新的杂货店，没有人工收银台。就像，每个人只是刷一下就走出门口。而且，你知道，我们出于某些原因做这些事情，但，你知道，它有这些负面后果，那就是剥夺了这种人际接触。我不知道。我认为特别是在现在疫情期间，我希望它提醒我们，我们都在某种程度上，
because we're all going through this crazy thing together, I hope it reminds us of our common humanity and makes people value that human contact, even with people that they don't know or don't know well. I think that's super interesting. And my big concern is, since my entire life is about bringing people together and giving them a sense of belonging,
因为我们都在一起经历这件疯狂的事情，我希望它提醒我们共同的人性，并使人们重视那种人际接触，即使是与他们不认识或不太了解的人。我认为这非常有趣。而我最大的担忧是，因为我的整个生活都是关于把人们聚集在一起并给他们一种归属感，
it seems that those people who already feel lonely fall into the loop of feeling like they're deserving to be lonely. And so as we try to now come out of this pandemic and more vaccines are available and we are seeing rates decrease of infection, my concern is that there'll be a whole collection of people who are moving towards the roaring 20s and then a whole lot of people who will feel more isolated than ever. And if we look back as far as 1985, the average American had just about three close friends besides family. By 2004, that was down to just about two. I think it was the University of Chicago study. And my concern around that is that the reason for it wasn't social
似乎那些已经感到孤独的人陷入了觉得自己理应孤独的循环。因此，当我们现在试图走出这场疫情，更多的疫苗可用，我们看到感染率下降时，我的担忧是，会有一群人走向“咆哮的二十年代”，而另一大群人会感到比以往任何时候都更加孤立。如果我们回顾到1985年，普通美国人除了家人外大约只有三个亲密朋友。到2004年，这个数字下降到大约两个。我认为那是芝加哥大学的研究。我对此的担忧是，原因不是社交
media. It wasn't anything that we currently blame. It was more likely that people moved away from their family after college for work. And so we've set up a very mobile society where social ties are, it becomes acceptable to let them go for the progress, kind of like you said, of, you know, the faster checkout line, the bigger promotion, the bigger office. But at a pretty significant expense. And so I really hope that we can all learn how to like apply your research because I think it would be great to be able to safely talk to strangers again. Yeah, so let's talk for a minute, Jillian, about the mental health benefits to these casual interactions and conversations. What have you found specifically? Well, the first study
媒体。不是我们目前指责的任何东西。更有可能是人们在大学毕业后为了工作搬离了家人。所以我们建立了一个非常流动的社会，社交关系变得，为了进步而放弃它们变得可以接受，就像你说的，你知道，更快的结账队伍，更大的晋升，更大的办公室。但代价相当大。所以我真的希望我们都能学会如何应用你的研究，因为我认为能够再次安全地与陌生人交谈会很棒。是的，那么让我们花点时间，吉莉安，谈谈这些随意互动和对话对心理健康的益处。你具体发现了什么？嗯，我做的第一项研究
I ran, which I did as part of my PhD, I ran at Starbucks. So I just stopped people on on the street and ask them if they would help out with the research study in exchange for a Starbucks gift card. So they had to go into Starbucks right then and there. And the only catch was that they had to follow some instructions when they went in. And so we asked some people to just be as efficient as possible, to have their money ready and avoid unnecessary conversation. We tried to tell them, you know, this will be a good thing for the people working there because they just want to get through their shift. But then other people, we said, when you buy your coffee, try and turn it into a real social interaction. Smile, make eye contact, have a little chat.
是我博士学位的一部分，我在星巴克做的。所以我只是在街上拦住人们，问他们是否愿意换取一张星巴克礼品卡来帮助完成研究。所以他们必须立刻走进星巴克。唯一的条件是他们进去时必须遵循一些指示。所以我们要求一些人尽可能高效，准备好钱，避免不必要的交谈。我们试图告诉他们，你知道，这对在那里工作的人来说是件好事，因为他们只想完成轮班。但对其他人，我们说，当你买咖啡时，试着把它变成一次真正的社交互动。微笑，进行眼神交流，聊几句。
And lots of people said, oh yeah, I do that all the time. And I said, okay, try to do it a little bit more. But when people came out with their coffee, what we found is that the people who had had that little chat, who turned that sort of everyday conversation that you might not even notice into something a little bit more social, they were in a better mood and felt more connected to other people. So those are the two findings that come up over and over again in my research and other people's research is just these mood, sort of well-being benefits, and this sense of connection to other people. So before the pandemic, research showed that we'd interact with anywhere from 11 to 16 people per day, whom we didn't know very well. And nowadays, I would venture to say most of us don't see any strangers for days on end.
很多人说，哦，是的，我一直这样做。我说，好吧，试着多做一点。但当人们拿着咖啡出来时，我们发现，那些进行了那次小谈话的人，那些把那种你可能甚至不会注意到的日常对话变成了一点点社交互动的人，他们的心情更好，感觉与其他人的联系更紧密。所以这就是在我的研究和其他人的研究中反复出现的两个发现，就是这些心情，也就是幸福感的好处，以及这种与其他人的联系感。所以疫情之前，研究表明我们每天会与11到16个我们不太认识的人互动。而如今，我敢说我们大多数人连续几天都见不到任何陌生人。
some social scientists have dubbed this turtling up. I really like that term. Are you concerned, is this going to have a long-term negative effect on people, do you think? I mean, that remains to be seen, of course. I think it could go either way. And like John said, it might go different ways for different people. I mean, I hope that a lot of people will start, well, because of the pandemic, have started to realize that it's not just the close friends and family who they probably have managed to stay in touch with throughout the pandemic. It's, you know, all these other people in our lives really do matter. And hopefully we're noticing that and we're missing them and we're realizing that maybe
一些社会科学家称之为“缩头乌龟”。我真的很喜欢这个词。你担心吗，你认为这会对人们产生长期的负面影响吗？我的意思是，当然还有待观察。我认为它可能向任何方向发展。就像乔恩说的，它对不同的人可能有不同的影响。我的意思是，我希望很多人会开始，嗯，因为疫情，已经开始意识到，不仅仅是那些他们可能在整个疫情期间设法保持联系的亲密朋友和家人。是，你知道，我们生活中的所有其他人确实很重要。希望我们注意到了这一点，我们想念他们，我们意识到也许
we should spend more time building up those relationships. So to the extent that that happens, you know, hopefully when we have more freedom of movement and freedom to be with other people, that people will sort of make even more efforts than they ever have to sort of build those relationships. But on the other hand, you know, we were talking earlier about social anxiety a little bit. Some people might, you know, we've just spent the last year basically being told that we should be scared of other people or we could interpret it that way, right? And so, you know, it's hard to shake that off. I mean, I know myself, like during the first, you know, first month or so of the pandemic, there's a park across the street for me. And the best thing for my sanity is
我们应该花更多时间建立那些关系。在某种程度上，如果这种情况发生，你知道，希望当我们有更多的行动自由和与其他人的相处自由时，人们会比以往任何时候都更加努力地建立那些关系。但另一方面，你知道，我们刚才谈到了一点社交焦虑。有些人可能，你知道，我们刚刚度过了过去的一年，基本上被告知我们应该害怕其他人，或者我们可以那样解读它，对吧？所以，你知道，很难摆脱那种感觉。我的意思是，我自己知道，就像在疫情的第一个月左右，我街对面有一个公园。对我理智来说最好的事情是
to go for a walk, which I do almost every day, just get some fresh air. And also it's a chance to see other human beings. But I remember the first couple weeks of the first lockdown, I was just feeling really nervous. You know, other people are possibly contagious and dangerous. And so, you know, if they were standing to walking too close to me, like, I just didn't want to be anywhere neither. I didn't even look at other people. And then I realized, you know, this is an over-the-top reaction. I can still keep a safe distance, but still smile and, you know, acknowledge other humans and our shared humanity. And I could, I can probably make a difference to everybody's feeling really anxious. I could maybe help people by just being friendly and, you know, trying to, again, like,
去散步，我几乎每天都这样做，只是呼吸点新鲜空气。而且这也是见到其他人类的机会。但我记得第一次封锁的前几周，我感到非常紧张。你知道，其他人可能是传染源和危险的。所以，你知道，如果他们站得离我太近，就像，我只是不想待在任何地方。我甚至不看其他人。然后我意识到，你知道，这是一种过度的反应。我仍然可以保持安全距离，但仍然微笑，你知道，承认其他人以及我们共同的人性。而且我可以，我可以对每个感到非常焦虑的人产生影响。我可以通过表现友好来帮助人们，你知道，尝试，再次，就像，
demonstrate this fellow humanity. It makes people feel good. It makes, it makes me feel good. If someone, you know, smiles at me in the park when I'm in a bad mood, it changes my day. So I hope that I can do that for other people too. So I think we, you know, we don't have to be scared, but we've, there has been a lot of fear over the last year and it would be easy for that to turn into a sustained kind of nervousness about interacting with other people and then have this negative cycle where, you know, we're out of practice. So we feel that we're not any good at it. So we don't do it. So we get even more out of practice. So I think that's the problem is that, you know, there could be this sort of downward spiral that makes it really difficult for people.
展示这种同胞人性。这让人们感觉良好。这让，这让我感觉良好。如果有人，你知道，在公园里对我微笑，而我心情不好时，它改变了我的一天。所以我希望我也能为其他人做到这一点。所以我认为我们，你知道，不必害怕，但我们，在过去的一年里确实有很多恐惧，如果这变成一种持续的对与他人互动的紧张感，然后陷入这种负面循环，你知道，我们疏于练习。所以我们觉得我们不擅长。所以我们不这样做。所以我们变得更加疏于练习。所以我认为问题在于，你知道，可能会出现这种恶性循环，使人们变得非常困难。
So, John, you're coming at this from a different perspective. You've thought a lot about how meeting new people can help build networks and accomplish goals. Is that why most people go to your events, do you think? Or do you think that they just want to meet new people and that there is some interest in, you know, saying hello to strangers? I think that there's a handful of reasons that people come to my events. we've really built it around four or five characteristics. So first and foremost, everything we do is novel, right? It's different than any other format.
那么，乔恩，你是从不同的角度来看待这个问题的。你思考了很多关于结识新朋友如何帮助建立网络和实现目标的问题。你认为这是大多数人参加你活动的原因吗？还是你认为他们只是想结识新朋友，并且对，你知道，向陌生人问好有一些兴趣？我认为人们参加我的活动有几个原因。我们确实围绕四五个特征构建了它。所以首先，我们所做的一切都是新颖的，对吧？它不同于任何其他形式。
We're not inviting people over for a casino-themed fundraiser or for a steak dinner or something like that. We're fundamentally inviting them over for an experience that they can't have anywhere else. And so I think that there's a whole collection of people who are drawn in by novelty. The second characteristic is curation, right? If you look at the really influential people in the world, they're willing to spend a fortune to enter the right rooms. And so you look at Davos, right? It's $250,000 or something to attend a freezing conference where you stand in the snow or slush of Davos hoping to bump into Andrea Merkels, right? And so if you can curate an environment with interesting people, especially from diverse backgrounds, then that becomes novel and interesting.
我们不是邀请人们参加赌场主题的筹款活动或牛排晚餐之类的。我们从根本上邀请他们来体验一种他们在其他任何地方都无法获得的体验。所以我认为有一群人是被新颖性所吸引的。第二个特征是策划，对吧？如果你看看世界上真正有影响力的人，他们愿意花一大笔钱进入正确的房间。所以你看看达沃斯，对吧？参加一个寒冷的会议需要25万美元左右，你站在达沃斯的雪地或泥泞中，希望能撞见安格拉·默克尔，对吧？所以如果你能策划一个有有趣的人的环境，特别是来自不同背景的人，那么它就变得新颖而有趣。
Now, I don't know if people are coming thinking that they can get a business deal. I think it's more because frankly, like, you know, I'm the one inviting everybody and I can do business with less than, I don't know, maybe 3% of the people. Like, I have no business to be done with Olympic medalists or Nobel laureates. I mean, it's just a completely different world. And so then I also think some people come because it's just a fundamentally generous experience. Most people are of the, at that level, everybody's after something from them. And so since I have no angle, then I think that they're coming for that as well. But so I think that's the starting point.
现在，我不知道人们来的时候是否认为他们能达成商业交易。我认为更多是因为坦率地说，就像，你知道，我是那个邀请所有人的人，我能和不到，我不知道，也许3%的人做生意。就像，我没有生意要和奥运奖牌得主或诺贝尔奖得主做。我的意思是，这是一个完全不同的世界。所以我还认为有些人来是因为这是一种根本上慷慨的体验。大多数人处于那个水平，每个人都想从他们那里得到什么。既然我没有目的，那么我想他们也是为此而来的。但所以我想这就是起点。
Now, what we also do digitally is really different than what we do in person. And we found that for digital events right now, everybody's been doing a lift and shift. They just take their in-person programming and make a much junky or worse version of it online. And so you end up on like an 800-person WebEx feeling like you don't matter. And so we try to make everything completely interactive and spend as much time as possible in breakout rooms playing games together and connecting. And the games really function as a social catalyst, both for them to get to know each other. And Jillian, my hunches you have tons of ideas on this, and also function as a great way to reduce stress. Because that pro-social behavior of play, when we're also anxious and wound up these days, I think is really effective at it.
现在，我们在数字上所做的也与我们亲自所做的非常不同。我们发现对于现在的数字活动，每个人都在做“复制粘贴”。他们只是把他们的线下活动拿过来，在网上做一个更糟糕的版本。所以你最终会参加一个800人的WebEx会议，感觉自己无关紧要。所以我们试图让一切完全互动，并尽可能多地花时间在分组讨论室里一起玩游戏和建立联系。这些游戏确实起到了社交催化剂的作用，既让他们互相了解。而且吉莉安，我的直觉是你在这方面有很多想法，也起到了很好的减压作用。因为这些天我们都很焦虑和紧张，我认为这种亲社会的玩耍行为非常有效。
I love what you're saying about not having an angle, like feeling like the people that you're talking to are not trying to get something from you. And it kind of connects to what I said earlier about, you know, what I think is happening if I talk to someone on the bus. And I think that there is that stage where they worry that I am trying to get something from them. But it's also something I think about in terms of networking, you know, because I've done a lot of work on how to talk to strangers. And I've run these how to talk to strangers workshops. I've been approached to help people with networking. And I'm like, I don't teach networking. I mean, you can't network without talking to people.
我喜欢你说的关于没有目的，就像感觉你正在交谈的人不是试图从你这里得到什么。这和你之前说的，你知道，如果我和公共汽车上的人交谈时我认为发生了什么，有点联系。我认为确实存在那个阶段，他们担心我试图从他们那里得到什么。但这也是我在网络方面思考的事情，你知道，因为我做了很多关于如何与陌生人交谈的工作。我举办过这些“如何与陌生人交谈”的工作坊。我曾被邀请帮助人们进行社交。我说，我不教社交。我的意思是，你不和人交谈就无法社交。
So in that sense, it is connected, right? And I'll definitely help, happy to help you, you know, train people on how to talk to each other. But I think lots of good things come even when you don't have an intention to get something. And I think the reason networking can feel a little icky is because it feels very instrumental. It feels like you're doing it for a purpose. And so people are sort of focused on the purpose rather than just focused on connecting. And so, yeah, I think when it's just you're doing it for enjoyment. and I definitely agree that it can often be a very pro-social thing to talk to other people as well,
所以从这个意义上说，它是相连的，对吧？我肯定会帮忙，很高兴帮你，你知道，培训人们如何互相交谈。但我认为即使当你没有意图得到什么时，也会有很多好事发生。而且我认为社交之所以会让人感觉有点“恶心”，是因为它感觉非常工具化。感觉你这样做是有目的的。所以人们更关注目的，而不是仅仅关注联系。所以，是的，我认为当你只是为了享受而做这件事时。而且我绝对同意，与他人交谈通常也可以是一件非常有益于社会的事情，
that those motives can result in other outcomes, but I think it goes more smoothly when you don't enter a conversation with that purpose. I love that you called networking icky, because I'm in complete agreement. I think it stinks. Research by Francesca Gino from Harvard Business School looked at the association to networking, and found that people feel the need to wash, because they feel so dirty from the experience. And so my hunch is that we're probably on a similar page in terms of my objective is not for anybody to network because that feels very unnatural, but for people to make friends.
这些动机可能会导致其他结果，但我认为当你不是带着那个目的进入对话时，它会进行得更顺利。我喜欢你称社交为“恶心”，因为我完全同意。我认为它很糟糕。哈佛商学院的弗朗西斯卡·吉诺的研究观察了社交的关联，发现人们感到需要洗澡，因为他们觉得这种经历让他们感到很脏。所以我的直觉是，我们可能在目标方面有相似的看法，即我的目标不是让任何人去社交，因为那感觉非常不自然，而是让人们交朋友。
Because everybody wants great friends. But nobody wants to feel like they're using some. I mean, maybe a handful of people do, but most of the people I want to interact with aren't interested in that. So, Jillian, how do you teach people to talk to strangers? How do you get started? Well, so I run these How to Talk to Strangers workshops, and I treat it as, I'm not, I try not to teach. I'm rather just facilitating because I think a lot of times people already know what to do.
因为每个人都想要好朋友。但没有人想感觉自己是在利用某人。我的意思是，也许少数人会，但我想要互动的绝大多数人对此不感兴趣。那么，吉莉安，你如何教人们与陌生人交谈？你是如何开始的？嗯，所以我举办这些“如何与陌生人交谈”的工作坊，我把它当作，我不是，我尽量不去教。我更像是在促进，因为我认为很多时候人们已经知道该怎么做了。
They just feel like they don't. Like they sort of build it up in their head as something that's really hard. But for example, starting a conversation, I mean, I've run this workshop, you know, not so many times, but, you know, half a dozen times at least. And people never have trouble coming up with. dozens of ways to start a conversation. So people know what to do. They just feel like maybe they're doing the wrong thing or maybe they should be doing something else. Maybe there's something better. So, yeah, I think it's mostly about helping people realize that it's not just them who feels
他们只是觉得他们不知道。就像他们把这在脑海中构建成一件非常困难的事情。但例如，开启对话，我的意思是，我举办过这个工作坊，你知道，次数不多，但，你知道，至少有六次。人们从来没有在想出开启对话的方法上遇到困难。几十种开启对话的方法。所以人们知道该怎么做。他们只是觉得也许他们做错了，或者也许他们应该做点别的。也许有更好的东西。所以，是的，我认为这主要是帮助人们意识到，不仅仅是他们感到
nervous and awkward about talking to strangers. It is a common thing. So I think what I've heard as feedback from these workshops is that that's often the biggest takeaway for people that just by talking to each other, because I use breakout rooms a lot, like what John was saying, like putting people into it and getting them to talk to each other and share their experiences, people really walk away realizing it's not just them and that other people are worried about the same things and that, you know, we can just be a little braver knowing that other people are acting the way they are because they feel nervous too. It's not that they don't want to connect. It's just that they're worried about the same things that you are.
紧张和尴尬，无法与陌生人交谈。这是一件普遍的事情。所以我认为我从这些工作坊中听到的反馈是，这通常是人们最大的收获，仅仅通过互相交谈，因为我经常使用分组讨论室，就像乔恩所说的，把人们放进去，让他们互相交谈并分享他们的经验，人们真的离开时意识到不仅仅是他们，其他人也担心同样的事情，而且，你知道，我们可以勇敢一点，知道其他人表现得那样是因为他们也感到紧张。并不是他们不想建立联系。只是他们担心和你一样的事情。
So just a lot of reflection, I guess, to answer your question is how do I teach people? It's just I get people to think about, okay, how can you start a conversation? What is your worst fear? Like, what do you think could go wrong? And then maybe think about, well, what could you do if that thing actually happened, which it probably won't. And then I especially talk about rejection because that is a big concern. So I talk about, I get people to think about what does rejection look like? Like how do we decide to interpret something as rejection?
所以只是大量的反思，我想，回答你的问题，我如何教人们？我只是让人们思考，好吧，你如何开启对话？你最大的恐惧是什么？就像，你认为什么会出错？然后也许思考一下，好吧，如果那件事真的发生了，你会怎么做，这可能不会发生。然后我特别谈到了拒绝，因为那是一个很大的担忧。所以我谈到了，我让人们思考拒绝是什么样子的？就像我们如何决定把某事解释为拒绝？
And then how could we, you know, thinking about those things like people not making eye contact or looking at their phone or looking at their watch or, you know, making some physical space? And say, well, what else could be going on? Could it be something other than a personal rejection? And people at first to have a bit of trouble coming up with other alternative explanations. But then once you get the ball rolling, people can quickly see, well, maybe that person doesn't speak English and is having trouble understanding me, or maybe they're worried they had a bad day at work, or maybe they're waiting for, they really are waiting for a phone
然后我们如何能够，你知道，思考那些事情，比如人们不进行眼神交流，或者看手机，或者看手表，或者，你知道，制造一些身体空间？然后说，好吧，还可能发生什么？这可能是个人拒绝之外的其他事情吗？人们起初在想出其他替代解释时有点困难。但一旦你让球滚动起来，人们很快就能看到，好吧，也许那个人不会说英语，理解我有困难，或者也许他们担心他们在工作中度过了糟糕的一天，或者也许他们正在等待，他们真的在等待一个电话
call because their dog is at the vet or, you know, like there's a lot of things that could be going on. And so the tricky thing about having a conversation is, of course, you can't read other people's minds. And so what we do is we somehow have this negative voice in our head and we invent all these stories about what's going on in the other person's mind. But most of that is not true. So I've done work on something called the liking gap, which is the fact that when you finish having a conversation with someone who's new, we tend to think that the other person didn't like us as much as we liked them. And it's just not correct. So again, it's just another example of how we worry more than we should. And like I said, it's because we can't read other
因为他们的狗在兽医那里，或者，你知道，有很多事情可能正在发生。所以进行对话的棘手之处在于，当然，你无法读懂别人的心思。所以我们所做的是，我们不知何故在脑海中有一个负面声音，我们编造了所有关于对方脑子里在想什么的故事。但大部分都不是真的。所以我做过关于“喜欢差距”的研究，这是一个事实，当你结束与一个新人的对话时，我们倾向于认为对方不像我们喜欢他们那样喜欢我们。这根本不正确。所以再次，这只是我们比我们应该担心的更多的另一个例子。就像我说的，这是因为我们无法读懂其他
people's minds. So I think that really resonates with people and maybe helps people feel a little braver that, you know, if you can convince people, actually, it's not as bad as you think, and people like you more than you think, then people might have a little, might be a little braver about starting a conversation. What about stopping a conversation? Do you explain to people how to do that? I'm thinking, yeah, because we were talking about networking a little while ago, and one of the things that I've always found at networking events is that you go up to somebody, you start talking, and then you say, oh, this person isn't going to be any help to me, and I want this conversation to stop. How can I stop it nicely and get away? Right. Well, I definitely do
人的心思。所以我认为这真的引起了人们的共鸣，也许有助于人们感到勇敢一点，你知道，如果你能说服人们，实际上，它并不像你想象的那么糟糕，而且人们比你想象的更喜欢你，那么人们可能会有一点，可能会在开启对话时勇敢一点。那么结束对话呢？你向人们解释怎么做吗？我在想，是的，因为我们刚才谈到了一点社交，我在社交活动中一直发现的一件事是，你走到某人面前，开始交谈，然后你说，哦，这个人对我没有任何帮助，我想结束这个对话。我怎么能礼貌地结束它并离开？对。嗯，我绝对会
talk about ending a conversation at the How to Talk to Strangers workshops, and it is the thing that I find the most difficult. So I said earlier that people can find dozens of ways to start a conversation, but ending one, people seem to find a lot harder and mostly people just lie. So they make up an excuse like they have to go to the toilet or they need to get to. the drink or they have to make a phone call or whatever. And a lot of the time, these are lies. Sometimes they are true. But a lot of times people are just saying this because they just don't know what to say. But every time I run this workshop, at some point, someone will just speak up and say that what they do is just thank the other person for their time and say it's time to go now.
在“如何与陌生人交谈”的研讨会上，我们谈到了如何结束对话，这恰恰是我觉得最困难的部分。我之前说过，人们可以想出几十种开启对话的方法，但结束对话似乎要难得多，而且大多数人只是在撒谎。他们会编造借口，比如要去洗手间、要去拿饮料、要打个电话之类的。很多时候，这些都是谎言。有时是真的，但更多时候人们只是因为不知道该说什么才这么说。但每次我举办这个研讨会，总会有人站出来说，他们的方法就是感谢对方抽出时间，然后说现在该走了。
You know, thank you, but we're done. And people kind of look at this person, whoever this one person is and think, what, you can do that? But there's brand new research just published a couple weeks ago from some folks at Harvard and other places looking at ending conversations. And they found that basically conversations never end. I think it was 2% of the times a conversation ends at exactly the moment that both people wished it would end. So sometimes people talk longer than they wish they would have. Sometimes people talk less time than they would have liked to. And again, it's this attempt to sort of coordinate with someone else when you can't read their mind. And so you might think that they, you know, that you can't stop talking because that would be impolite.
你知道，就是说“谢谢，但我们谈完了”。人们看着这个人，无论他是谁，都会想：“什么？你竟然能这么做？”但哈佛大学和其他机构的研究人员几周前刚发表了一项关于结束对话的全新研究。他们发现，基本上对话永远不会真正结束。我想只有2%的对话是在双方都希望结束的那一刻恰好结束的。所以有时人们谈话的时间比他们希望的要长，有时比他们希望的要短。这再次体现了在无法读懂对方心思的情况下，试图与他人协调的困难。所以你可能会觉得，你不能停止说话，因为那会很不礼貌。
But it seems that the best bet is just to, you know, at the networking event, the example that you're giving is just say, you know, thanks. It's been nice talking to you. We're here to network. So let's go and do that. I think we can do it in a polite way. I think it's so interesting because my general view is not to go to a networking event and instead find shared activities that actually interest people. So I'd almost rather go on a hike, right, with people or start a run club or some kind of board games night and give an excuse to either invite people or join ones that already exist. So there's like lists and lists and lists of things on meetup.com or event bright or so on that give us an opportunity to connect with people in a much more natural context than a bunch of overly priced alcohol in a room that has loud music in it.
但最好的办法似乎就是，比如在你提到的社交活动中，直接说：“谢谢，很高兴和你聊天。我们来这里是为了建立联系，那我们去忙别的吧。”我认为我们可以用礼貌的方式做到这一点。我觉得这很有趣，因为我的总体观点是不要去参加那种社交活动，而是去寻找人们真正感兴趣的共同活动。我宁愿去徒步旅行，或者组织一个跑步俱乐部，或者举办某种棋盘游戏之夜，找个借口邀请别人，或者加入现有的活动。Meetup.com或Eventbrite上有很多这样的活动，让我们有机会在比那种放着吵闹音乐、酒水昂贵的房间里更自然的环境中与人建立联系。
because it just feels like such an unnatural environment. And I used to, when I was in my single days, I used to explain to people that I'm not a fan of clubs because I'm not so good looking that anybody would want to talk to me at a club because you can't hear the person. But I'm much better at a bus stop because I'm decent at having a conversation. I think another thing that that taps into, John, is just introversion. Like, I'm very much an introvert. And I always try to mention that when I talk about this research because I don't want people to walk away thinking, oh, well, it's just, you know, it's only extroverts that are going to do crazy stuff like talk to a stranger.
因为那感觉太不自然了。我单身的时候，曾向人们解释过我不喜欢去夜店，因为我长得没那么帅，没人会在夜店里想跟我说话，而且你也听不清对方在说什么。但在公交车站我就好多了，因为我擅长聊天。约翰，我认为这还涉及到了内向的问题。我本人就是一个非常内向的人。我在谈论这项研究时总是试图提到这一点，因为我不希望人们离开时认为：“哦，好吧，只有外向的人才会做像和陌生人说话这种疯狂的事情。”
I would never want to go to that environment where the music is loud and there's 100 people. Like, that's just overwhelming for an introvert like me, which is a, you know, a large minority of the population. And so these kind of situations that you're describing are much more comfortable for someone like that. And I find these kind of one-to-one conversations are just not scary for an introvert. Like I talk to strangers all the time because it doesn't feel scary to me. I mean, it's taken some time to get there. It's not something I've done my whole life. And there has been some skill building that makes these conversations go better, which makes me feel more comfortable with them.
我绝不想去那种音乐吵闹、有一百人的环境。对于像我这样内向的人来说，那简直太让人不知所措了，而内向者在人口中占了很大一部分。所以你描述的这些情况对这样的人来说更舒适。我发现这种一对一的对话对内向者来说并不可怕。我经常和陌生人交谈，因为这对我来说并不觉得可怕。当然，我花了一些时间才达到这种程度。这不是我一生都在做的事情。通过一些技能的培养，这些对话变得更顺畅了，这也让我感到更自在。
But I can walk away. These are not conversations that are intended to last for a really long time. And so it's very low stakes to me. And I find that maybe it especially suits an introvert. John, I'm just wondering, I mean, a lot of what you do to bring people together involves reaching out to strangers. What kinds of reactions do you generally get? Oh, I get everything.
但我可以随时离开。这些对话并不是为了持续很长时间，所以对我来说风险很低。我发现这可能特别适合内向者。约翰，我很好奇，你所做的很多促进人们聚在一起的事情都涉及接触陌生人。你通常会得到什么样的反应？哦，什么反应都有。
I mean, I have literally gotten, I think the best response saying no was I don't do blind dates, which I thought was hilarious. I was like, respect. To speak to what Gillian was pointing to about trying to understand what's going on in another person's head, the incredible amount of social anxiety that highly influential people have was staggeringly shocking to me, like unbelievable. I mean, famous directors, actors, musicians, like all of it. I've even had an actor say to me, I know how to be anybody but myself. And so when I'm me, I'm awkward. And this is somebody that you would know by name. You've seen this person in film and on television. And I think that there's this misperception often of other people's social capability
我的意思是，我真的收到过各种回复。我觉得拒绝得最好的回复是“我不参加相亲”，我觉得这太搞笑了。我当时想：尊重。说到吉莉安提到的试图理解对方在想什么，那些极具影响力的人所承受的巨大社交焦虑让我感到震惊，简直难以置信。我的意思是，著名的导演、演员、音乐家，都是这样。甚至有演员对我说：“我知道如何扮演任何人，除了我自己。所以当我做回自己时，我很尴尬。”而这还是一个你叫得出名字的人。你在电影和电视上都见过这个人。我认为人们对其他人的社交能力往往存在误解。
because you think that they're successful or impressive. And so the most, odd one I've ever gotten. Most odd response was actually from a famous psychologist. I'm not going to say who it was. But you absolutely know who this person is. And the response was something to the extent of how dare you invite expect me to pay for a dinner where I'm usually the person who's honored at the dinner. And we responded very politely and we were like, I don't know. What made you even think that there's a fee? We pay for everything. And everybody in attendance is, you know, very successful and interesting and so on. Unsurprisingly, we never got a response back. But it's, it took us a really long time to figure out what to put into the emails, what frequently asked questions, how frankly not to sound overly exclusive. So we work really hard to curate, but we are not like a.
因为你认为他们很成功或令人印象深刻。我收到过最奇怪的回复其实来自一位著名的心理学家。我不会说出是谁，但你绝对知道这个人是谁。回复的大意是：“你怎么敢邀请我，还指望我为晚餐付费？我通常是晚餐上的贵宾。”我们非常有礼貌地回复说：“我不知道是什么让你觉得有费用？我们支付一切费用。所有出席的人都非常成功且有趣等等。”不出所料，我们再也没有收到回复。但我们花了好长时间才弄清楚邮件里该写什么，常见问题解答该怎么写，坦率地说，如何听起来不显得过于排外。所以我们非常努力地策划，但我们不是那种……
nightclub. We're not trying to keep people out just for the sake of seeming cool. It's just that I can't afford to pay for millions of people's meals. So we kind of keep it small. And then we also launched a salon series that's more open to the public if kind of people just message me. We're often happy to just host them. And we have a nonprofit arm that just runs programming for the public. So we try to really be inclusive of everybody. But the responses we get are kind of just hilarious at times. So, Gillian, what research are you working on now? What are your next, the next questions that you want to answer?
夜店。我们不是为了显得酷而把人拒之门外。只是我负担不起数百万人的餐费。所以我们保持小规模。然后我们还推出了一个沙龙系列，如果人们给我发信息，我们更愿意向公众开放。我们很乐意接待他们。我们还有一个非营利部门，专门为公众开展项目。所以我们尽量做到包容所有人。但我们得到的回复有时确实很搞笑。那么，吉莉安，你现在在研究什么？你接下来想回答的问题是什么？
Well, it occurred to me one day that I've been studying these, you know, conversations with strangers are in some sense a difficult conversation for many people. People find it a difficult thing. And I was talking earlier about all the different fears that people have. And it occurred to me one day that there's other kinds of conversations that might have might involve similar fears. So I'm thinking of things like talking to someone that you know who's just lost their partner or someone who's had a miscarriage or someone who's been diagnosed with cancer. And so I just got really curious about whether there's kind of a common set of
嗯，有一天我突然想到，我一直在研究这些……你知道，与陌生人的对话对许多人来说在某种意义上是困难的对话。人们觉得这是一件难事。我之前谈到了人们所拥有的各种恐惧。有一天我想到，还有其他类型的对话可能涉及类似的恐惧。比如和刚失去伴侣的人交谈，或者和流产的人，或者被诊断出患有癌症的人交谈。所以我真的很好奇，是否有一套共同的……
fears that people might have if maybe the fears that people have about talking to strangers might be similar to the fears that people have in these other kind of conversations. So that's what I'm studying right now, and I have an ongoing study that I'd love some help with. So anybody who wants to check out my website at jillian sandstrom.com, if you've experienced one of these things, cancer diagnosis, miscarriage, or bereavement relatively recently and want to talk about what people have said to you in an attempt to be supportive, I would love to hear from you. We'll make sure to put that link in the program notes. Thank you.
恐惧。人们对与陌生人交谈的恐惧，是否与他们在这些其他类型的对话中所感受到的恐惧相似？这就是我目前正在研究的内容，我有一个正在进行的研究，希望能得到一些帮助。所以任何想查看我网站（jilliansandstrom.com）的人，如果你最近经历过这些事情之一——癌症诊断、流产或丧亲，并且想谈谈人们为了支持你而对你说过的话，我很乐意听听你的经历。我们会确保把链接放在节目说明中。谢谢。
And, John, what about you? What's your next project? Oh, wow. Well, so I have the book coming out. You're invited, The Art and Science of Cultivating Influence. And I think that my biggest focus is finding a whole collection of ways to just help people come together. So whether it's wild pop-ups in New York that I get people to volunteer to run and do activities in public at safe distances now that summer's coming, or it's online experiences and events that we can just disseminate so that people can have this, conversations, whether it's with strangers or with their family reunions, because right now everybody's doing like happy hours. And I'll be honest, I'm not a huge fan of promoting drinking when you're stressed. I don't think it's like the social cues that are the best for us. And also by the third time your company runs the happy hour, you're like, okay, we're going
那么约翰，你呢？你的下一个项目是什么？哦，哇。嗯，我有本书要出版了，《你被邀请了：培养影响力的艺术与科学》。我认为我最大的重点是寻找各种方法来帮助人们聚在一起。无论是纽约那些我让志愿者去运营的疯狂快闪活动，还是在夏天到来之际在公共场所保持安全距离进行的活动，亦或是我们可以传播的在线体验和活动，让人们能够进行对话，无论是与陌生人还是与家人团聚。因为现在每个人都在做“欢乐时光”。老实说，我不喜欢在压力大时提倡喝酒。我不认为这是最适合我们的社交方式。而且当你的公司第三次举办欢乐时光时，你会觉得，好吧，我们要……
to have the same conversation, the same, you know, extroverts are going to take over the conversation. I'm going to stay quiet, turn the camera off, wash my dishes, and feel like, okay, I've shown up, so I'm not going to get in trouble. But if we could give people activities, conversations to have games, maybe ways to even include their kids, so people kind of get to know the extended family, right? Right now, we're not having the hallway conversations, the water cooler conversations that reduce anxiety and give us a peek into people's lives. but we're actually seeing directly into their homes. Maybe we could use this as an opportunity to really get to know each other. And so that's the kind of stuff I'm exploring. And then I've a really big mission, which is I find that most of the sales processes that companies go through are like a huge waste of money.
进行同样的对话，同样的……你知道，外向的人会主导对话。我会保持安静，关掉摄像头，洗碗，感觉“好吧，我露面了，所以我不会惹麻烦”。但如果我们能给人们提供活动、对话游戏，甚至包括孩子在内的方法，让人们了解大家庭，那该多好？现在，我们没有了那种能减少焦虑、让我们窥见他人生活的走廊谈话或茶水间谈话。但我们实际上是直接看到了他们的家。也许我们可以利用这个机会真正地了解彼此。这就是我正在探索的内容。我还有一个非常宏大的使命，那就是我发现公司经历的大多数销售流程都是巨大的浪费。
And a lot of the marketing budgets are really wasted because they don't create a meaningful relationship between, the company and people. And so, you know, I'm never going to be remembered for anything. But if I am, it's that I got the most influential people in our culture to come to my home, cook me dinner, wash my dishes, clean my floors, and then thank me for it. And if I can do that with no budget, then companies are spending way too much trying to connect with their customers. And so if we can create actual sense of community or belonging or connection, and it doesn't need to cost a lot, Maybe we could shift the entire marketing world. So your aspirations aren't that big then, just shifting the entire marketing world.
很多营销预算都被浪费了，因为它们没有在公司和人之间建立起有意义的关系。所以，你知道，我永远不会因为任何事情而被记住。但如果我被记住了，那是因为我让文化中最有影响力的人来到我家，为我做饭，洗碗，打扫地板，然后感谢我。如果我能在零预算的情况下做到这一点，那么公司在试图与客户建立联系上就花得太多了。所以如果我们能创造出真正的社区感、归属感或联系，而且不需要花费很多钱，也许我们就能改变整个营销世界。所以你的抱负并不大，只是改变整个营销世界而已。
Marketing world, yeah. Well, always aim high, right? Well, I want to thank you both for joining us today. I don't know about you, but I certainly feel happier and healthier having spoken to you both. Thank you. Thank you for having me. This is such a treat. Nice to meet you, John.
营销世界，是的。嗯，目标总是要定得高一点，对吧？好吧，我要感谢你们两位今天加入我们。我不知道你们怎么想，但我确实因为与你们两位交谈而感到更快乐、更健康。谢谢。谢谢邀请我。这真是一种享受。很高兴见到你，约翰。
Gillian, you're awesome. And I look forward to speaking to more strangers. Great. Well, you can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at www.combeatingof Psychology.org or on Apple Stitcher or wherever you get podcasts. And please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org.
吉莉安，你太棒了。我期待着与更多的陌生人交谈。太好了。好吧，你可以在 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Stitcher 以及你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有意见或想法，请发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。那是 Speaking of Psychology，连在一起，at apa.org。
Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyin. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. I'm sorry about the bird. I hope they can get him out of the recording. Are you kidding? That's my favorite part. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《心理学谈话》由 Lee Wynerman 制作。我们的音效编辑是 Chris Kondyin。感谢收听。我是美国心理学会的 Kim Mills。很抱歉有鸟叫声。我希望他们能把它从录音中去掉。你在开玩笑吗？那是我最喜欢的部分。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。